[拍手]
tanu
ん
[拍手]
酒井てリラックマと申しまして1隻の
付き合いの程お願い致します
私大学で落研ま落語研究会に所属している
ものでございましてまあ女性ですけど
こんな風に男物の着物を着て日々落語の
練習に励んでおります
まあ確かに楽号といったらこうおじいさん
がやっていうイメージが多いかもしれませ
んがまあそうですねこのように女性でも
大学生の女子でも落語をするという人は
結構な数いまして
まぁ私もそのうちの一人でございます
けれども
今回このような機会に読んでいただいて
まずありがとうございます
まあ
そうですね今回女性を選んパー面とする
ような企画ということでそのような落語を
書いてきて欲しいと頼まれて
いやー非常に困りましたね
まず最初に言っておきたいのが楽号という
のは飲む打つ買うの世界の話でございます
飲む打つ買う
まずこの飲むというのはお酒を飲む
3個目の打つというのがあ
ですね博打を打つ
3つ目の買うというのが女を買う吉原
なんかがあった世界の話でございますから
このような
話が主流になっているわけでございます
けれども今ないこと言ったら怒られそう
ですねなんか追い出されやしないかと今
ビクビクしておりますが
この世界の話だからまあそういうことしか
できない
のではなくて略語の一番いいところは
それぞれのオリジナリティが発揮できると
いうところが落語乗っててもいいところで
ございますまぁこんな世界の話ではあり
ますけれども
まあその話をする人本人が高
自身のオリジナリティを発揮してその話を
変えたりとか時代の流れに合わせた面白さ
をつくっていくっていう一番新しい
エンターテインメントなんじゃないかと私
は考えております
今回私くしがご用意したお話は女の子の日
という話でございます
まあ
まあ察しの良い方はわかると思います
けれどもこれ映画の半券が安くなる女の子
だけ安くなる姫とかではなくて
月のものの話ですね
こういう話を人前でするべきではないと
いう風潮がありますが私はその逆だと思う
んですね
まあ
高
女子がつらい思いをしているのを隠して
男子と同じところに立つというのではなく
てまあ辛さを一緒に
共有して乗り越えていこうという世界の方
がなんかこう
フレンドリーというか本当に
の意味でジェンダーフリーなんじゃないか
なと思っております
それは1隻の付き合いの程お願い致します
いやー今日は10バター
いやだね団子屋なんて忙しいに決まってん
だからさぁいや小遣い稼ぎになるからね
おやじの店手伝ってはいるものの
こうなってくれたなぁ絶対忙しいなぁ行き
たくあっ付いたと言ったんだぞ
オヤジなんだよあのねぇ早速着てもらって
悪いんだけどさー
お園の様子見に行ってくれないかな
あさな
何かあったやんこないんだよ
どうなってるかちょっと様子見に行って
くれ
麻生上がったじゃあ行ってくるよ
絵をそのがなぁ手伝いに来ないなんてやり
でも振っ
いや今日は十五夜だからなぁ月にはウサギ
れが住んでるって言うからうさぎでも降っ
ていくんじゃないな twitter
ツイート
あーさーらー
あっそらー
おっしゃだー
朝ラー
あーそらー
だようるさいであんたああああ小正
をその基地婆じゃないが生んだ静かにして
くれ
そんなこと言ったってさをそのどうしたん
だ言ったいやねー
今日は具合が悪いんで
近いっ
そんなわけないだ何を言ってんでー
いやそんな日もある肌ってお蕎麦なって
この町内で一番元気な奴なんだぞそれ具合
が悪いなんてありえないでしょんなわけ
ないじゃないか絵をそのが具合悪い日だっ
てねうんいやそんなことはない
あいつはねまあわからないけどねあの
どんなウイルスが蔓延したっとってね彼女
はそういう日間ないそういう人なんで
そんなこと言えるんで会やね今日はねー
から女の子の日なんだよ
何ん
女の子のにいやだから
月のものの日
月のもの
じゃあ月のものねっきーのものね月の
なんてなんだろう
お付きの者か青月のを築きなものねはやう
月の a
あんな体操等のんだねーおそばにいた
羽振りがいいねぇ
何言ってるんだねっ
a でもそうがえっ
今だけ
そうそうだねまあでも月に1回のことだ
からね画面してくるえっ
月に1回しか来ないの
ちょっと自覚が足りないんじゃお前何言っ
てるんで
ねえ女には誰でもあることなんだしょうが
ないだろ
女に会ったってことおばさんにもっとあっ
たよ空ねぇまぁでも最近は来なくなった
からそう
実家に帰っちゃった
何を言ってるんだまあまあとりあえずね
ああそういう理由なんだから顔そんな具合
が悪いんだ8学科えっ
だったよええ
そっかロックあおつきのものが遅なんねー
だって仕事を休んでお付きの者をとって
言ったらねぇ
あそらー
色々あってもおかしくないあー空具合が
悪いに決まってんで ai っっやるな
意外と
あ
た大和おーがいな祭
ああどうだった姉をそのはなんか付きの
ものがどうみたいなこと言ってね具合が
悪いって創価へ大変なんだらそっかそっか
女ってのは一度も大変なもんでそう俺にも
来てほしいけどね落ち生
いやーなんか話だけ聞いてるけどねなんか
大変だって言ってたよあそうなの
飲んでなんかねえ
痛いとかなんとかと a
そいつ暴力振るうを開け
dv 野郎じゃないか何を言ってるんえっ
まあまあ俺もそんなに知らないけどなぁ
まあをそんな大変なんだからお前人一倍
働くぬはいわかりました
いやー今日は疲れたらええ本当にあんなに
コキ使うことでじゃないかなぁ
やマナーでもではお土産なおだんごも
もらえたしいや今日は良い夜で
月山をきれいだね本当に
いやーでも結局お付きの者ってら何だった
んだろうなぁ
を
うさぎじゃないかええ珍しいレゴんだった
ドラ美
え者 a
真っ白い売り物みたいだね
エッセふーっ
喋った
いや何を失礼なことをする
我はあ月から来た視察団であるん
視察ださっ視察アンプこの遠く離れた青い
保持地球のこと調査しに来たお前運がいい
な俺がお前路を築きなものに染めシェル
俺はね
お付きの者が欲しいって話をしてため堂前
の大槻なものにならないといけうるさい
なぜ true ねその代わりの日だ
県方を月度もになるなるああ
その耳伸びるんだらそこの宮の日
吉尾月のものだえっお前の会に連れてけっ
スレって蹴って会やだなまた好みが黙って
ない変な拾い物しちゃったーーーー全く
うん
いやー昨日変な夢見ちゃったなぁへ
好きなを車キハトってちょっとれねえ儲け
てるのからんいや一お前起きたな古美味
なるままなんだよええ
夢じゃなかっ
わーいつは台の下あ俺が朝食べようと思っ
てた団子がもう全部ねーじゃねーか
なるほどこれは団子と色 a
なかなか美味であったもええなぁ本当に
ああそうだ今日店番の悲哀アーミー系
あそっでるからいいエロス嫌いっうまいっ
私は団子とやらがたくさんあるその場所に
ついて下いやーだよ村えっこんなとこに
入って踊ら住んでこんな歩きにくいじゃ
ねーか
でろでろってこのみんな黙ってない
うるさいなぁ本当にお前ちょっと喋って
みるが伸びるだけのただのウサギじゃない
かほっ
翔丸ないなぁもう全く太田つどうしたんだ
よな彼だって抑えたやオヤジへいやいや音
や
a べっ
なんでもねえなんでもねってことはねえ
だろ a からでも入ってるのかああーー
やねぇ
いやあこう
好きなものがきちゃっ
えっ
月のものきた
きたっ
お前女だったのかいや父が受けるまあそう
か
時代はジェンダーフリーって言うからな
ソープけどねいやー
よりもね大変だねこれが来てたのか女に
暗雲さあ大変だ
ああそうかそうかだいぶ重いようだったら
な病院たらどうだ重い
まあ重いけど
秒いく
いかないって大江の車便のかいや喋るんだ
ようちのは水珍しいな珍しいっていうか
なんていうなんまあまあそうかニュー
スタンダードなんかもしれないなぁいやー
ねああああそうなんだけどさーそうだ動か
せてくれないからだもういいけどね
ちょっと今一人が度は来てねあの手伝って
ほしいね手伝うのいやいいけどなの作業鉄
なんでねぇ談合つく作業やってほしいんだ
よなああそれまだ任せてくれよだって
こっちに8月のウサギがいるんだからな